[Music]
our team is the heart soul of this very
Beach protecta Bay at all costs
[Music]
everyone on the beach is talking about
you guys this is Victoria Leeds the new
owner of the Hunley Club I know that the
club's probably not your scene but you
have a standing invitation all the bad
[ __ ] happening on our Beach started once
she took over my balls say we need to go
over there and check it out i ball say
just think it he's right just chill
what the [ __ ] your ball sound like three
year old girls I don't know man that's
just how they talk but they're wise
yeah undercover yeah little 200 cover
you think I'm a drug dealer honey look
at me oh don't even start
[Music]
[ __ ] lifeguards take care of them
already why are we in the morgue what's
coming what are you now
now we hide weird it's just a little
dead man's fat stop being a baby
[Music]
make my pecs a little bigger and don't
cover up my front bump you got it huge
dick big dick we're sending to the best
year